[Applause]
[Music]
this week's games are a total throwback
it's the return of 90s platformers
16-bit RPGs and virtual reality which i
guess is actually still a thing sort of
anyway if you like that stuff make sure
to subscribe to be the first to know
about all the hottest trends now let's
take a look at the sizzling games coming
this week I'll be honest with you guys
banjo-tooie is my favorite game of all
time so ukulele being its spiritual
successor has me very excited in case
you live under a googly-eyed rock here's
the pitch it's from X rare developers
cool it stars a talking chameleon and a
bat cool and it has colorful levels like
a jungle and a casino in a big frozen
mountain literally cool along the way
you'll collect tons of items fight
bosses and learn new powers ukulele
leaps onto ps4 xbox one and pc on
tuesday april eleventh with a nintendo
switch version and the works for later
this year if you want to learn more
right now head over to gamespot for our
full review it's time to dust off that
PlayStation VR headset for star blood
arena in the future people like to watch
pilots fight each other in spaceships
star blood arena puts you in the cockpit
as one of those pilots where you can fly
nine different ships and rain down all
sorts of bullets and lasers and missiles
you can do that in a variety of modes
including single-player and co-op
challenges a sports mode and of course
online free for all multiplayer star
blood arena takes off on april eleventh
let's return to Earth with the sexy
brootal now I know what you're thinking
what is the sexy brootal well it's a
fancy mansion turned into a casino where
a bunch of people are about to die you
play as the old priest love cardio boon
your goal is to prevent all those tragic
deaths cue the groundhog day scenario
where left cardio relives the same day
again and again trying his best to
prevent each death as he learns why the
casino guests are dropping like flies
he's basically Phil Connors but like
solving murders do you ever have déjà vu
mrs. Lancaster I don't think so but I
could check with the kitchen you can
start on ps4 xbox one and pc on the 11
ok let's go back to space cosmic star
heroine is inspired by the likes of
Chrono Trigger and Phantasy Star and it
looks just like those Super Nintendo
classics you take control of agent
Alyssa LaSalle who's just been outed by
her galactic agency which gets the
attention of all her adoring fans and
all the bad guys she's ever fought and
speaking of fights they all happen right
there on the map with classic turn-based
combat that lets you stack party attacks
for big heavy hitting combos you can
start your adventure on ps4 Vita and PC
on the 11th and now we're coming back
down to earth again this time it's to
Zen out with stardew valley collector's
edition if you missed this indie spin on
the classic Harvest Moon formula last
year here's a new chance to grow crops
go fishing explore caves raise a family
and so much more the collectors edition
is the first time the game will be
available physically and it includes a
mini guidebook fold-out map of the game
world and a copy of the game's killer
soundtrack you can grab it on xbox one
or ps4 on the 11th and those are the
hottest games will be playing this week
as always remember that release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and I'll be back with more games
next week